hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i had a request in a
couple of youtube comments to test this
product from japanese company through
tech
called the ncf clearline ac optimizer
they call it
it's a little thing you plug into um
your ac outlet and it's supposed to
improve uh improve the fidelity of your
equipment uh you can see it here it
looks very close to this ps audio noise
harvester so i assume it was same kind
of idea and that it had a filter in
there and
would attempt to reduce the noise on ac
line as you'll see in a second it's not
what it is but anyway um it was cheap
enough for me to buy it and it was about
236 dollars from amazon us
so when i said cheap i mean cheap for me
to buy it and as far as these tweaks go
obviously people spend thousands of
thousands of dollars on these kinds of
products so to them is it's a bargain
when you try to read the website it is
very hard to figure out what this thing
is and what it does there's so much
mumbo jumbo terminology used in there
alpha occ air coil in the ncf
clear line i mean it just goes on and on
with that terminology
but prior to testing it i was doing this
research and and i watched a video in
there and i was surprised when they made
this stark comment and he says this
passive which doesn't mean anything but
he says the line and the neutral which
are the two conductors that uh carry in
power in your ac the other one's safety
ground
it claims that they're not connected in
any shape to each other and don't form a
circuit either meaning there's nothing
from one pin to the other and if there's
nothing electrically from one pin to the
other then there can't be a filter in
there electrical filter electrical
filter needs to have a return path so it
always has two pins
if you take a light and hook it up to
one terminal in your battery nothing
comes on you gotta complete the circuit
so i realized well this is not what i
expected it to be it's not like a noise
harvest there and so watch the short
youtube video they have the stuff's not
on their website unfortunately and i
grabbed two of the frames in here
so and they show the insides of it and
basically what it has is that there's
these coils in here in that is a piece
of wire that's been coiled but it only
connects to one pin on your ac terminal
the other side as you can see is an
insulator and then it doesn't go to the
other side and same with the other one
so you basically have a wound coil with
one end of it connected with the other
end either not connected or is connected
to the
nylon plastic enclosure in either case
there is no electrical connection
anywhere
so what a coil or inductor would do in
this case is basically nothing it's not
an electrical device it may be some
mechanical device and vibrate in there
but it can't possibly
perform any electrical functionality and
i'll measure and confirm that
on this thing and they talk about how
this
little piece of wire wrapped around
eliminates resonances coming from power
outlets uh what resonances to begin with
is unclear what is resonating and how
this little
curled up piece of wire will
change that uh you know that
characteristics whatever it is
and you can see a little bit better
image of it here in another uh frame
that i grabbed in here again you can see
these things in here the center pin goes
directly to that connected to the uh
terminal here
but the other there is no i mean there's
no other side to it so very very
puzzling uh on this thing um they show a
couple of review samples in there of
course as is typical with these devices
a whole bunch of people gushing over it
and the first one from a japanese person
fukudasan
says that it removes high frequency
noise well we can measure high frequency
noise and i'll show you that in a second
the second reviewer says the same thing
it says incredible improvement in signal
noise ratio well signal noise ratio is
snr and i show it in every review i do
so very objective stuff of course the
company doesn't show any of that
measurement whatsoever but we can remedy
that
the biggest issue is is what i see is
just becoming so common in these power
products they have no regulatory
certification whatsoever this is
something that's going to plug into the
wall
i want to know it's safe i mean if it's
going to be left in there all the time
does it generate heat is there some
conductivity in this nylon that they
have that maybe if i touch it i may get
a shock
i didn't find any problems like that but
you know we need a proper regulatory
certification for these things let's say
a surge comes in and few thousand volts
get conducted across these two terminals
is this going to catch on fire is it
going to melt is it going to smoke is it
going to do something bad
in u.s you know you got to have this
kind of thing ul certified by
underwriter laboratories uh there is ce
certification for europe csa etl
no marking on their website no marking
in the uh
packaging that i have it came with a
little manual there's nothing
i can't find a single reference to any
safety check now if this thing was being
sold for five dollars should be one
thing but but uh japanese company uh
uh not uh getting a certification or
something they charge 230 dollars for
just sell 10 of these and would probably
pay for a quick ul testing because
there's not much to this thing so i
don't imagine the testing would be very
expensive on this thing so
even if it did everything it said it did
this is just you know really shameful
and shouldn't be the case
as i said it's can very common or it's
always been common i don't know but
every time i grab one of these things
there's no safety certification so on
that basis alone i would say don't buy
buy this product but let's keep going
now my typical stance with any power
products is to first measure my ac power
and see what noise and distortion it has
and then plug this device into the ac
and see if the ac is improved
it doesn't get any simpler than that now
measuring it is a little bit more
complicated than that you're talking
about high voltage mains and you can't
just take that and stick it into the
audio analyzer and blow up the audio
analyzer so i use a special uh probe is
differential probe
that uh
divides the input by 100 so 122 volts
becomes 1.2 volts and then the analyzer
doesn't mind that and 1.2 volts is
typical audio signal so i can get the
full resolution of audio precision
analyzer i have applied to ac analysis
so as you can see on the right side i
can see every nuance of that ac waveform
all the noise in it all these dirty
spikes in there and all that is all in
there and if you look on here this thing
instead of being a very pretty sine wave
at the tops of it they're a little
messed up there's also a little glitch
in here something right around that part
of the uh ac waveform is kicking in and
pulling some power and causing that
little glitch in there so it'll be a
good test case to see if this product
filters or removes anything in there we
see that it's essentially 60 hertz which
is what we want and if we treat this as
an audio signal the ratio of the good
part of this power which is uh um that
what we want is ac power pure 60 hertz
in here to all the junk that it has is
about 31 db difference between those two
and then so i went ahead and then
without changing anything it's pretty
easy because everything is running i
just plugged this in take another
snapshot of the analyzer output and we
see that the sine add remains the same
uh the voltage is basically the same
this and you know these digits vary even
if i don't change anything so 0.1 you
know db doesn't mean anything but it was
31 now and it was with 31 before we had
this junk spikes over here these are all
unwanted
and they're all unwanted here and no
difference and even that little glitch
happily survived
and came right out of the ac
so at this point we know that this
device is not a filter of any sort
despite the company's claims there's
just nothing has been filtered
and we're going this time i'm measuring
all the way up to 1 megahertz so about
25 times higher than
audio audible bandwidth and
it's usually very easy to filter these
this part of the spectrum many products
do that but of course they're outside of
audible band don't matter and at any
rate your audio equipment already
filters these things
so very disappointing that the product
does absolutely nothing of course
electrically we would know it does
nothing as i explained you know just
connecting a few turns of wire into to
the each up excuse me through each
pin of your ac of course gonna have no
electrical effect
um before testing it actually i did hook
up a multimeter to this and a
very sensitive multimeter uh special one
design lcr meter and i measured that
there is indeed no connection from the
safety ground to either pin or between
the pins so there's no re the resistance
is basically too high for me to measure
they're completely insulated from each
other i measured it as an inductor it
did not measure any inductance at all
it did measure a little bit of
capacitance two picker for it and two
picofarads two puffs as we call it is
nothing i mean i could just breathe on
the probe and i get too big of earth so
basically these three pins are
electrically completely isolated from
each other so therefore nothing can be
shunted and nothing can be taken from
one pin and dumped onto the ground and
what have you and the measurements prove
that and that's why this waveform all
the needs distortion and noise remains
completely untapped intact
and then if we look at it in more detail
basically that fft that i showed you i
can just plot it by itself
and uh you can see again our
mains which is what we want the wanted
signal all the way up to 1.2 megahertz
here i've got one of them in red which
is raw ac and the other one is with the
ncf clear line plugged in and you can
see these two land on top of each other
all the noise is the same all the junk
is the same everything's the same so it
basically does nothing
at this point we could just stop and say
well if the ac signals never change of
course anything you plug into it's going
to work the same way
but you know less less you know human
claims of the company
so i set up my audio precision analyzer
to basically test itself and i told it
to output four volts and measure four
volts and i got a signal noise ratio of
almost 134 db
um this is about 25 db better than
threshold of hearing
um and you know that's what i expect
from my high performance audio analyzer
and this is with ryzee i then plugged in
the clear line into it and naturally it
made absolutely no difference if you
know you have to go two digits past the
decimal point before you even see that
and again that's just run to run
variation so
no difference whatsoever in the
performance of the audio analyzer and
then we can look at the spectrum of the
noise now of course it's much much
cleaner we see that the worst case noise
is minus 125 minus 130 db
this is our you know main tone and this
is all the extra distortion if you will
all hugely below audible band and
then the key is whether i plug in the
clear line or don't plug it in
you know performance remains identical
and
you know it's just nothing there
now people at this point always say i
don't watch these graphs i don't
understand the graphs but you know what
does it sound like well i like devices
like this because they're quick to test
i can be playing music i can plug it in
and i can unplug it and nothing gets
interrupted if i was testing it you know
power condition and i have to disconnect
the power replug it in restart
everything and by then your memory of
what something sounded you know is long
gone but with this music plays and i can
just plug and unplug it and listen
carefully so for this testing i use my
rme dac deck
which is a thousand dollar high
performance stack it's my everyday deck
that i have on my desk and these are my
dan clark stealth headphones the world's
lowest distortion headphone that i've
ever measured and they're sealed and
that means it isolates the noise my
room's pretty quiet anyway but with this
being closed in
it blocks out the noise it's a four
thousand dollar headphone so i hope
somebody doesn't
say hey your device is not uh
your headphone wasn't uh high enough
resolution it's higher resolution than
anything other people might have
and so i then queued up some of my high
performance high performance reference
tracks that i have with extremely good
resolution and
and channel separation and imaging and
what have you and i listened and uh i
would plug this thing in and unplug it
plug it in unplug it plug it in and plug
it it absolutely makes no difference and
it shouldn't because that's what the
measurements say
it didn't do anything to the ac signal
so therefore the rest of your audio
product not going to change change
either
there was some talk about resonance
assume they mean mechanical resonance so
maybe you have a speaker system do
something for those kind of resonances
so i actually banged on my power strip
that powers all my audio equipment i
could not hear anything any
contributions without this even then i
plugged this in and i banged on it a few
times you know i hit it and everything
and there was nothing coming through the
headphones that i was listening to
so
there's just there's just nothing there
it can't be anything there whoever
thought of this circuit and this this
design clearly has no
real understanding of electricity and
electronics where they confuse a you
know piece of wire just dangling in the
air as having some electrical function
i didn't i don't think i showed you the
amazon
website where i bought it uh look at
this what it says is this exceptional
noise removal effect i mean
if it's exceptional if it means it's so
much the effect is so large i should be
able to instantly tell
that it's there and and of course there
isn't so
this and combined with the fact that it
has no regulatory certification just
means you're basically throwing away 230
dollars and and tying up an outlet and
uh
it just does nothing so if i'd known
what it did i probably wouldn't have
been bought it i would have just said
look it does nothing you know it can't
do anything there's no circuit there but
they're wrapped all that stuff in so
much mumbo jumbo on their website that
uh
it's hard to det find out the little
key information which has no circuit in
there there's basically nothing there
so maybe you could stick a toothpick in
there in the outlet it might be better
than what this thing does because it's
not an electrical circuit
all right so hopefully whoever asked me
to buy this is happy about it um
um you normally when i buy products and
i test them i keep them and
unfortunately i test a lot of bad
products so i have like rooms and rooms
full of uh bad products that i get stuck
with since nobody wants to take them
from me after i review them say they
don't do anything good but in this case
i'm actually going to return this i
think there's the claims of the company
this is that reduces noise it made me
think it's a real electrical filter and
the fact that it's not i feel like even
i was misled but as much as i know i
thought this thing was a real ac filter
and therefore it has some value and it
doesn't so i'm actually going to return
this to amazon to the japanese seller
who i feel bad for shipped it all the
way from japan to me but uh i just think
the message needs to get through them
and through the bar you know prototype
that hey you know there are people who
properly analyze these things and even
with my ears or with equipment i can't
find this thing to do anything it's just
chunk of plastic or nylon whatever it's
made out of with absolutely no useful
function
okay hopefully you enjoyed this video
see you in a future one bye